tomorrow is the 20th anniversary of 9
11. the biden administration is
reviewing
saudi arabia's connection to the attacks
15 of the 19 hijackers were saudi
citizens holly williams got rare access
to a prison in saudi arabia where
inmates were convicted of terrorist
activity are held holly good morning
good morning the saudi government has
consistently denied any involvement in
the 9 11 attacks but inside a saudi
prison we heard from inmates convicted
on terrorism charges who said their
upbringing in an ultra-conservative
islamic kingdom contributed to their
radicalization saudi officials say
they're now fixing the problem
this is one of the rooms yes this is we
were given a guided tour of al hayes
prison by one of its inmates
is here yasser essam hamdi was born a
u.s citizen to saudi parents in baton
rouge louisiana i remember that going to
disneyland in the yeah in florida i
think
it was very nice
his family moved to saudi arabia when he
was five he told us and just before the
9 11 attacks he went to train with the
taliban in afghanistan where he was
captured by u.s forces i am a young man
a teenager
going with these people i started to
have some extremist
practice
hamdi renounced his u.s citizenship and
returned to saudi arabia a free man but
was later arrested by saudi authorities
i didn't want to speak about it a lot
yeah okay yeah
but
talking and stuff like that and because
of that i came back to prison
saudi arabia says it's recently
revolutionized this prison an effort to
reform inmates with music
sports and even a company run by the
prisoners themselves which manufactures
perfume very nice and furniture the
prisoners in charge wore business suits
during our visit we were filmed by
inmates and accompanied at all times by
prison officials
critics of the saudi government say
political prisoners have also been held
here saudi officials deny allegations of
torture
several of the inmates described growing
up in a closed-off islamic country
exposed to fundamentalism and the
glorification of violence did you ever
hear any extremism at a mosque did you
hear
um
you know extremist views at school
yeah of course of course
now saudi arabia says it's promoting
so-called moderate islam extremist
preaching has been banned and school
textbooks that once promoted violence
against non-muslims have been rewritten
yasser essam hamdi told us he'll be
released in a year and dreams of somehow
reclaiming his u.s citizenship i was an
extremist extremist once but now i am
not
saudi arabia's won praise for its
efforts to fight terrorism and modernize
but continues to be criticized over its
human rights record gail
holly williams reporting from saudi
arabia thank you in the